Esiste un linguaggio che nessuno ti ha
insegnato, non ha parole, non ha
grammatica, eppure viene pronunciato
intorno a te ogni giorno, nelle stanze,
negli sguardi, nel modo in cui qualcuno
inizia una frase e poi non la finisce.
La maggior parte di noi non ha mai
sentito questa lingua. Ci troviamo nel
bel mezzo di una conversazione che negli
ultimi 10 minuti ha preso una direzione
completamente diversa da quella che
stavamo effettivamente dicendo e non ce
ne accorgiamo nemmeno. Torniamo a casa
pensando: "Bella conversazione, non
pensiamo, c'era qualcosa di
interessante. Immaginate un uomo in
piedi in una stanza illuminata a giorno
che giura che è buio. Non sta mentendo,
semplicemente non ha mai imparato a
usare gli occhi. So come si sente
quest'uomo. Sono stato come lui, non per
qualche mese, ma per anni. Questo ci
succede ogni singolo giorno, non solo
una volta nella vita, ma ogni settimana.
La luce è accesa, è sempre stata accesa.
Eppure continuiamo a brancolare nel buio
lungo i muri, chiedendoci perché non ci
succeda mai niente. La parte amara non è
il rifiuto in sé. Il rifiuto passa in
fretta. La parte amara è non sapere mai
cosa sarebbe potuto essere. Non si
accumulano sconfitte, si accumula il
vuoto. C'è una cosa che devi capire
prima di iniziare. Una donna interessata
raramente lo dice esplicitamente e non
perché stia giocando, è perché
l'attrazione non si annuncia.
L'attrazione si rivela, si manifesta
nella distribuzione dell'attenzione,
nella scelta del luogo, in ciò che
qualcuno ricorda di te, anche se era
insignificante. Nel momento in cui
qualcuno smette di recitare la parte
della versione perfetta di sé, non si
tratta di coincidenze, si tratta di dati
e si può imparare a leggere i dati.
Questa è la buona notizia di tutto il
video. Non serve talento, solo pratica.
Gli uomini che hanno un talento naturale
non sono diversi da voi. Hanno
semplicemente iniziato a prestare
attenzione a un certo punto e poi non
hanno smesso per 15 anni.
ones do that eco. La parte che quasi
nessuno dice non vedere un segnale non è
un errore. Può succedere vedere un
segnale e poi non fare nulla perché si
aspetta la certezza assoluta. Quello sì
che è un errore perché mentre tu
aspetti, aspetta anche lei, prima o poi
si fermerà. Oggi imparerà i quattro
segnali. Niente trucchi, niente formule,
niente affermazioni su ciò che
presumibilmente tutte le donne hanno in
comune. Quattro schemi che hanno un
significato reale perché hanno un
prezzo. E cosa ancora più importante,
imparerai cosa fare quando li vedi,
perché vederli e basta non ha mai
aiutato nessuno. Mi chiamo Daniel. Non
parlo qui per darvi delle spiegazioni
sulle donne. Parlo da persona che ha
impiegato 10 anni per vedere ciò che
aveva sempre avuto sotto gli occhi.
Accendiamo la luce. Parte 1. Il
paesaggio del non parlato. Prima di
poter interpretare un segnale è
necessario comprenderne il motivo
dell'esistenza.
Perché non dice semplicemente quello che
vuole? La risposta più facile è: "Perché
le donne sono complicate." Questa
risposta è comoda, è popolare, ma è
sbagliata, non spiega nulla e non ti
aiuta per niente. La vera risposta è più
scomoda. Mostrare interesse è un rischio
per tutti, anche per te. Nel momento in
cui esprimi il tuo interesse per
qualcuno, dai a quella persona il potere
di rifiutarti. Ecco perché tutti
procedono con cautela, un po' di
intimità, un po' di apertura. E poi
valutano cosa ricevono in cambio. Non è
una caratteristica esclusivamente
femminile, è la meccanica fondamentale
di qualsiasi relazione tra due persone
che hanno qualcosa da perdere. Anche tu
fai la stessa cosa, solo che non la
chiami così. La differenza sta nella
pratica. Chi dedica la propria vita ad
imparare a moderare il proprio
interesse, a mostrarlo e a ritirarlo, a
suggerirlo e a eluderlo, diventa abile
nel farlo. Non si tratta di una
questione di carattere, ma di
allenamento. Questo porta a qualcosa che
cambia completamente la tua
comprensione. I loro segnali non sono lì
per confonderti, sono lì per metterti
alla prova, ma non nel modo in cui
pensi. Non stanno mettendo alla prova la
tua intelligenza per risolvere un
enigma. Stanno mettendo alla prova la
tua capacità di guardare, la tua
presenza, la tua capacità di recepire
ciò che ti stanno inviando. La maggior
parte degli uomini fallisce questo test
perché lo trova un enigma. Lo
analizzano, dissezionano singole frasi,
inviano screenshot ai loro amici e
chiedono cosa intende dire con questo. E
mentre analizzano sono assenti. Ecco
l'ironia e l'ho sperimentata
personalmente. L'uomo che cerca con più
diligenza il codice è proprio quello che
trascura l'ovo, perché la sua mente è
bloccata nel puzzle, non nella stanza.
Ricordatelo per tutto ciò che segue. Non
siete dei crittografi, non dovete
decifrare nulla. Dovete osservare.
Osserva come cambia la temperatura di
una stanza quando una determinata
persona vi entra. Osserva dove si posa
la sua attenzione quando nessuno la
guarda. Osserva cosa rimane quando la
cortesia viene meno. È lì che tutto ha
inizio. Part A2. La grammatica della
cortesia. Ora arriva la parte più
importante di questo video ed è proprio
questa la parte che manca in quasi tutti
i video su questo argomento. Devi
imparare a distinguere tra cordialità e
interesse genuino, perché è proprio qui
che falliamo in massa e in modo molto
costoso. Impariamo a riconoscere alcuni
segnali. Sentiamo, se ride, le piaci, se
ti tocca le piaci. Se ti ascolta le
piaci. E poi passiamo la vita
interpretando ogni donna gentile come un
invito. Questo porta a due disastri
contemporaneamente. Diventi invadente
dove non c'era nulla e perdi fiducia
nella tua percezione quando le cose
vanno male finendo per ignorare la
realtà per anni. In questo modo li
separiamo nettamente. La cordialità è
simmetrica, ti tratta più o meno allo
stesso modo in cui tratta il cameriere,
il suo collega, il suo vicino. Ride di
te e ride di tutti gli altri. È calorosa
con te e lo è con tutti i presenti nella
stanza. È un tratto caratteriale, non un
segnale rivolto a te. L'interesse è
asimmetrico, fa la differenza. Ti dà
qualcosa che nessun altro nella stanza
ha. Questo è tutto il test. Una sola
parola. Differenza. Ricevi più
attenzioni degli altri, più tempo, più
apertura, più domande? Ti è più vicina
che a chiunque altro? Si ricorda di te
meglio? Se la risposta è no, significa
che hai a che fare con una donna
gentile. Punto. Non è una sconfitta, è
un'informazione e per di più preziosa
perché ti evita di passare settimane a
inseguire qualcosa che non c'era. Se la
risposta è sì, allora la cosa si fa
interessante. E un secondo strumento,
prima di passare ai segnali, contesto.
Un collega che lavora con te per due ore
si avvicinerà a te più di uno
sconosciuto. Una donna in un locale
rumoroso si sporgerà verso di te perché
altrimenti non ti sentirebbe. Una
cameriera sorride perché è il suo
lavoro. Niente di tutto ciò è un
segnale. È fisica ed economia, non
attrazione. Un cartello è valido solo se
non spiega già la situazione. Tenete
saldamente questi due strumenti. Saranno
il supporto di tutto il resto,
differenza e contesto. Senza di essi
ogni segno è privo di valore. Con essi
ogni segno diventa preciso. Smettete di
cercare prove. Iniziate a cercare le
differenze. Segno uno, l'economia
dell'attenzione. Il primo segno è il più
antico, il più onesto e il più
trascurato. L'attenzione non mente. Le
persone possono controllare le proprie
parole, possono controllare la propria
espressione facciale, ma nessuno può
controllare per ore e ore dove il
proprio sguardo vaga spontaneamente
quando non ci sta pensando. Inoltre,
l'attenzione è la risorsa più scarsa che
una persona possiede. è limitata. Ogni
minuto che le dedichi non lo dedichi a
nessun altro. Ecco perché è un segnale
importante, perché ha un prezzo.
Immaginate una situazione con diverse
persone, una cena, una birra dopo il
lavoro, una festa, una riunione che si
trasforma in una chiacchierata di
circostanza. Presta attenzione a dove si
sofferma quando la conversazione si
interrompe. Quando un gruppo si
scioglie, ognuno deve decidere di nuovo
a chi rivolgersi. È un momento
imprevisto e nei momenti imprevisti è
l'individuo a decidere, non le
convenzioni. A terra vicino a te di
nuovo e ancora una volta. Una volta è
una coincidenza. Tre volte in una sera
significa che la decisione è stata presa
tre volte. Osservate il loro sguardo
quando qualcuno racconta una
barzelletta. C'è un piccolo movimento
che quasi nessuno nota, ma che rivela
quasi tutto. Quando qualcuno sente
qualcosa di divertente, istintivamente
cerca il volto della persona alla cui
reazione è più significativa.
Non la persona che ha raccontato la
barzelletta, la persona che conta. Se il
suo sguardo continua a posarsi sul tuo
viso, hai appena visto qualcosa che non
ti direbbe mai. Presta attenzione a come
ascolta. Non si ascolta, ma come
l'ascolto educato attende la fine,
l'ascolto interessato interrompe, pone
domande, ritorna su una proposizione
subordinata che hai lasciato cadere 10
minuti prima, ne vuole di più. Infine la
prova dell'interruzione. Cosa succede se
qualcun altro interrompe la vostra
conversazione?
La persona educata si sente sollevata.
Chi è interessato si irrita brevemente,
ma poi torna. Questo ritorno è uno dei
segnali più chiari che esistono. Aveva
tutte le ragioni per interrompere la
conversazione, non le accolte. Cosa
farne? Restituiscili completamente. Il
telefono via, non capovolto sul tavolo,
ma via.
>> [sbuffare]
>> lo schermo dietro di lei, il suo sguardo
fisso su di sé, non sulla porta, non
sulla stanza, non sulla prossima persona
che potrebbe essere più interessante.
Non c'è niente di più raro del trovarsi
seduti uno di fronte all'altro con tutto
il proprio essere. Nulla è così facile
da dare, eppure quasi nessuno lo fa. Se
lei ti presta attenzione e tu rispondi
solo a metà, non hai fatto una bella
figura. Hai risposto? E la risposta era
no. Parte 3, il controllo delle
interruzioni.
Restiamo ancora un attimo sul tema
dell'attenzione perché c'è una sfumatura
che quasi tutti gli uomini interpretano
erroneamente.
Alcune donne dimostrano interesse
importunandoti. Può sembrare
contraddittorio, ma non lo è. stai
lavorando a qualcosa, un progetto, un
gioco, un libro, una conversazione con
qualcun altro e lei appare con una
domanda che non è una vera domanda, con
un'osservazione che non richiede una
risposta, con qualcosa che in realtà
dice "Guardami". Credi davvero che abbia
bisogno della tua opinione su una
questione così banale proprio ora? No,
sta cercando di mettersi in contatto. Ed
ecco che arriva il momento in cui
perdiamo in massa, non per il rifiuto,
ma per qualcosa di molto più piccolo.
Reagiamo con fastidio. Non forte, non
scortese. Solo quel breve, quasi
distratto, m con lo sguardo fisso sullo
schermo, con quel secondo e mezzo di
ritardo prima di voltarci, lei se ne
accorge immediatamente e si allontana
con garbo, in silenzio, senza dire una
parola. Non torna più. È così che
muoiono la maggior parte delle
possibilità, non con un sonoro no, ma
con 30 piccole risposte quasi
inesistenti. Cosa farne? Girati
completamente con tutto il corpo, non
solo con la testa. Fermati per 30
secondi, bastano pochi secondi. Non devi
rinunciare alla tua serata, devi solo
dimostrare che vale la pena fare questa
pausa. E se siete davvero occupati,
ditelo con gentilezza e con un chiaro
seguito. Finirò tra 10 minuti, poi la
serata sarà vostra. Non un rifiuto, un
appuntamento. La differenza tra non ora
e presto e non vedo l'ora è la
differenza tra una porta che si chiude e
una che rimane aperta. Segno 2, la
geografia della prossimità. Il secondo
indicatore è spaziale ed è così
affidabile perché quasi nessuno pensa
consapevolmente a dove si trova. Le
persone si dispongono nello spazio in
base a ciò che provano sempre,
involontariamente. Ci sono due livelli e
il secondo è quello più interessante. Il
primo livello è la distanza. Lei si
avvicina più del necessario, si siede
sul posto accanto a te, anche se ci sono
altri quattro posti liberi. Rimane con
te quando il gruppo si disperde. Sì, è
un segnale, ma è uno di quelli che
conoscono tutti ed è soggetto a
interpretazioni errate. Bar affollati,
cucine anguste e uffici piccoli
impongono la vicinanza. Ricoda il
contesto. Il secondo livello è più
preciso. Allineamento. Non badare a
quanto è vicina. Presta attenzione a
dove sta indicando. Piedi, ginocchia,
spalle, petto. La parte superiore del
corpo di una persona indica dove è
rivolta la sua attenzione, anche quando
il suo viso guarda altrove. Ecco perché
questo è così rivelatore. Se sta
parlando con qualcun altro, ma i suoi
piedi e la parte superiore del corpo
sono rivolti verso di te, significa che
fisicamente sta parlando con qualcun
altro, ma mentalmente con qualcun altro.
Viceversa vale lo stesso principio e
bisogna essere abbastanza onesti da
interpretarlo in questo modo. Se ti
parla in modo amichevole mentre è
rivolta verso la porta, sta solo essendo
gentile e se ne sta andando. Poi c'è un
terzo punto che ha un peso maggiore di
entrambi, il ritardo nel dire addio.
Presta attenzione al finale. Il finale è
la cosa che mente di meno. Chi vuole
andarsene se ne va. Chi non vuole
andarsene inventa delle ragioni per
restare. La giacca che improvvisamente
si mette addosso con molta cura, l'unico
argomento che gli viene in mente
all'improvviso, i tre passi verso la
porta e poi il voltarsi indietro.
L'ultima frase era in realtà la
terzultima: "Chi rimanda il saluto non
vuole che finisca. Nessun segnale è più
eloquente nel dire l'ovio. Cosa farne?
Innanzitutto notalo e non andartene. Se
il saluto si protrae, prolungalo insieme
a lei. Non essere l'uomo che è già mezzo
vestito mentre lei sta ancora parlando.
In secondo luogo, e questo è
fondamentale, se avete osservato questo
prolungamento per tre volte, allora
ponete fine ad esso, non aspettando di
vedere se si accentua ulteriormente, ma
affermando l'ovo. Mi piacerebbe
continuare se non stessimo entrambi
guardando verso la porta. Sei libero
giovedì? È lì che sta la magia. Nessun
trucco, nessuna tecnica, nessuna
formula. Un uomo che ha visto la
situazione e l'ha espressa a parole,
invece di sperare che si risolvesse da
sola, perché, e ricordatelo, lei può
aprire le porte, basta attraversarle.
Una breve nota. Se finora hai trovato
utile questo video, metti un like, ci
vuole solo un secondo e aiuta il canale
più di quanto tu possa immaginare. Ora
passiamo al terzo segnale, il più
discreto di tutti. Parte 4, il
linguaggio dell'allineamento. Una
piccola e pratica aggiunta al secondo
cartello, perché in pratica fa tutta la
differenza. C'è un errore che quasi ogni
uomo commette non appena inizia a
prestare attenzione al linguaggio del
corpo, osserva e poi smette di
partecipare. Conosco quest'uomo meglio
di quanto vorrei ammettere. Ero lui.
Sedevo lì tenendo mentalmente traccia di
tutto. Piedi rivolti verso di me,
capelli che mi sfioravano. Risate. Sì.
Uno statistico nel bel mezzo di una
conversazione e proprio per questo,
completamente assente, la donna seduta
di fronte a me non si è accorta che la
stavo osservando. Ha notato solo che
qualcosa non andava, che non c'era
nessuno veramente presente. Quindi
questo non è uno strumento per la
conversazione in corso, ma per dopo.
Durante la conversazione sei nel bel
mezzo della conversazione. Dopo,
tornando a casa in cucina, nel momento
in cui ti chiedi se è successo qualcosa,
fai un bilancio. E un'altra cosa che vi
risparmierà molta confusione, se
prestate attenzione all'allineamento,
allora prestate attenzione a modifica,
non a determinate condizioni. Una
singola immagine non dice quasi nulla,
ha braccia incrociate, significa forse
un rifiuto? No, forse ha freddo, forse è
semplicemente seduta in quel modo. Le
cose si faranno interessanti quando
qualcosa cambierà. Braccia incrociate
che si aprono mentre parli, un corpo che
si allontana lentamente dal gruppo e si
avvicina a te nel corso di 20 minuti.
Una distanza che si riduce senza che
nessuno faccia un passo. Il movimento è
informazione, non stato. Infine,
l'errore più comune di tutti. Alcune
persone sono semplicemente fisiche,
toccano il braccio di tutti mentre
parlano, stanno vicine a tutti. Questo è
temperamento, non un segnale. Torniamo
allo strumento, differenza. Ricevi più
degli altri, allora questo è importante.
Ricevono tutti la stessa cosa. Allora è
semplicemente nella loro natura e non ha
nulla a che fare con te. Segno tre. La
memoria come confessione. Il terzo
segnale è il più debole. Non emette
alcun suono, non è visibile in nessun
video, eppure è più affidabile di
qualsiasi altro di cui abbiamo parlato
finora. Lei ricorda cose che non avevano
motivo di essere ricordate. Pensate un
attimo a come funziona la memoria. Non
ricordate ciò che era importante, ma ciò
che occupava la vostra mente. Il nome
del tuo vicino scompare in tre giorni.
Una clausola subordinata di qualcuno a
cui pensi spesso persiste per mesi. Per
tanto, ricordare è una confessione. Se
lei ricorda qualcosa di insignificante
su di te, non significa che abbia una
buona memoria, significa che occupi uno
spazio nella sua mente maggiore di
quanto vorrebbe ammettere. Presta
attenzione ai dettagli che la riportano
indietro. il nome di tua sorella? Che
avevi quell'appuntamento dal medico
questa settimana? Che non ti piace il
coriandolo, che una volta hai accennato
al fatto che suonavi il pianoforte tre
settimane fa di sfuggita e che tu stesso
te ne sei dimenticato. E poi lei chiede:
"Suoni ancora? Questo è proprio il
momento. Nulla di questa domanda è
casuale. Si è aggrappata a una frase
senza valore, se l'è portata dentro per
settimane e poi te l'ha restituita.
Presta attenzione alla ricorrenza
dell'argomento. Tornerà su qualcosa di
te che per lei è importante. Il tuo
lavoro, i tuoi viaggi, qualcosa che un
tempo ti appassionava. Sta cercando un
modo per tornare a ciò che la interessa.
Esiste una terza variante ancora più
forte. Lei ricorda qualcosa che avrebbe
potuto sapere solo se stesse ascoltando,
mentre tu pensavi che non lo stesse
facendo. Cosa farne? due cose. La prima
è ovvia, eppure non viene quasi mai
fatta. Prendine atto, non con un
complimento, ma con attenzione. Te ne
sei ricordato a questo è tutto ciò che
serve. Dillo con calma, con calore,
senza farne un dramma, ma dillo perché
le stai dimostrando la stessa cosa che
lei ha dimostrato a te. Il messaggio
arriva il secondo. Rispondi punton come
tecnica, ma come conseguenza. Se lei si
ricorda cose di te, allora inizia a
ricordare cose di lei, non in unapp per
gli appunti, ma nella tua mente perché
sei interessato. E se non sei abbastanza
interessato da ricordarlo, allora hai
appena imparato qualcosa di importante
su te stesso e dovresti essere
abbastanza onesto da rifletterci fino in
fondo. Non c'è quasi nulla che rafforzi
un legame più velocemente del momento in
cui qualcuno si rende conto "Mi hai
ascoltato quando non era importante".
Parte 5, il ritorno dell'argomento.
Esiste una variante del terzo segno che
vive nel mondo digitale e poiché metà
dell'approssimazione avviene oggi in
tale ambito, merita una sezione a
sestante. Presta attenzione a chi
riprende la conversazione.
una conversazione finisce finisce
sempre, prima o poi, amichevolmente,
senza un motivo preciso, semplicemente
perché entrambe le persone avevano altro
da fare e poi semplicemente rimane lì.
La domanda è chi lo raccoglierà? Se è
sempre lei a rianimare una conversazione
ormai spenta con un'immagine, un
pensiero, un a proposito, allora non è
un caso. Avrebbe potuto lasciar perdere
e nessuno se ne sarebbe accorto, ma non
l'ha fatto. Inoltre, prestate attenzione
alla qualità, non alla quantità. Non si
tratta della velocità con cui risponde.
Questa regola è assurda e ha fatto
impazzire innumerevoli uomini. Le
persone hanno un lavoro, figli, giornate
storte. e batterie scariche. Il punto
cruciale è lei risponde. Una parola è
una fine, una domanda è una
continuazione.
Chi è interessato ti fornisce il
materiale per continuare, fa domande,
parla troppo, introduce nuovi argomenti
senza che ce ne sia bisogno. E
l'indicatore più forte di tutti: lei ti
racconta cose che nessuno ha bisogno di
sentire. che il treno fosse stato
cancellato di nuovo, che il suo gatto
avesse fatto qualcosa di sciocco ed è
per questo che aveva dormito male. Cose
assolutamente banali. Ed è proprio per
questo che sono così significative,
perché le cose banali non si condividono
con i conoscenti, ma con le persone che
si desidera avere nella propria vita
quotidiana. Se una donna ti sceglie come
rifugio per i suoi piccoli momenti,
significa che ti ha già internamente
categorizzato in modo molto più preciso
di quanto ammetterebbe mai. Cosa farne?
Accettalo senza analizzarlo
eccessivamente. Reagisci come se fosse
qualcosa di importante, perché lo è, non
per il suo contenuto. Allora rimandate a
un certo punto, non subito, ma nemmeno
dopo 4 mesi, dite la frase che quasi
nessuno dice. Qui parliamo molto,
facciamolo davanti a un caffè, piuttosto
[schiarire la voce]
ciò che rimane una semplice
chiacchierata per sempre non è un
preludio, è una sala d'attesa. Segnal
four, vulnerabilità volontaria. Ed
eccoci arrivati al segnale che la
maggior parte degli uomini ignora
completamente, non perché sia nascosto,
ma perché non sembra un segno di
attrazione. Sembra una brutta giornata.
Ecco cosa devi capire. Ognuno di noi
presenta in pubblico una versione di sé
che funziona, la versione composita,
quella che non offre alcun bersaglio per
gli attacchi. Per le donne questa
immagine viene spesso costruita con
particolare cura perché il costo di un
eventuale crollo è più elevato, vengono
giudicate più rapidamente, vengono
etichettate come troppo più rapidamente.
Pertanto è un segnale molto importante
quando si toglie questa armatura in tua
presenza. Presta attenzione al momento
in cui smette di suonare la versione
buona, ti racconta di qualcosa che la
imbarazza, ti dice di avere paura di
qualcosa di piccolo e ridicolo, ammette
di essere insicura riguardo a qualcosa
in cui apparentemente sembra sicura di
sé. dis, "Non lo so, anche se di solito
ha sempre una risposta, oppure, e questa
è la spiegazione più sottile, è
semplicemente stanca di stare in tua
compagnia, senza pretese, senza
umorismo, silenziosa, non interessante.
Le persone non sono stanche di chi vuole
impressionarle, sono stanche di chi non
sono più tenute a prestare attenzione.
Se smette di parlarti significa che ti
ha promosso. Esiste una versione ancora
migliore, ti fa entrare nel suo mondo,
ti parla di sua sorella con la quale le
cose sono complicate. Menziona i suoi
amici per nome, come se tu li
conoscessi. Ti chiede se vuoi unirti a
lei sabato quando si incontrerà con
loro. Non si tratta di un invito
casuale. Le persone non includono nella
propria cerchia ristretta chi non
desiderano avere al loro interno. Cosa
farne? E fate attenzione, perché è qui
che si verificano i danni maggiori. Non
riparare nulla. Per anni è stato il mio
riflesso ed è il riflesso di quasi tutti
gli uomini. Lei ti mostra qualcosa di
morbido e tu ti trasformi immediatamente
in un tutto fare. Hai tre soluzioni. Le
spieghi perché non dovrebbe prenderla
così sul serio. Le dici "Andrà tutto
bene, avevi buone intenzioni, ma hai
appena chiuso la porta, perché in realtà
quello che stai dicendo è questa
situazione è un problema. Per favore,
metti la fine. Ciò che serve invece sono
2 secondi di silenzio e una frase che
non risolve nulla. Sembra davvero
estenuante. Continua. Sì, ho capito. Poi
resti lì, tutto qui. Rimani lì e non ti
agiti. Un uomo capace di tollerare la
vulnerabilità senza cercare di
eliminarla è raro e le donne ricordano
un uomo così per moltissimo tempo.
Quindi la cosa più importante, rispondi,
la vulnerabilità funziona solo in modo
reciproco. Se lei si apre e tu rimani
chiuso, si crea uno squilibrio di potere
e gli squilibri di potere sono, in
definitiva, fonte di disagio. Alla fine
lei si sentirà esposta e tu al sicuro. E
nessuna relazione può resistere a una
situazione del genere. Restituisci
qualcosa, non il tuo segreto più grande,
ma qualcosa di reale, un'insicurezza, un
dubbio, qualcosa che per te ha davvero
un significato e per cui ti rendi
vulnerabile. È a questo punto che
l'interesse si trasforma in connessione.
Parte 6. La legge dell'accrattamento.
Ora abbiamo quattro segnali: attenzione,
vicinanza, memoria, vulnerabilità. Ora
arriva la regola senza la quale tutti e
quattro diventano pericolosi. Nessun
singolo simbolo ha un significato
preciso. Lo ripeto perché tutto internet
dice il contrario. Un singolo carattere
non ha alcun significato. Completamente
privo di significato. Ha riso inutile.
Ti ha toccato il braccio? Inutile. Si è
ricordata del tuo compleanno. Inutile.
Le persone ridono, le persone si
toccano, le persone ricordano. Ciò che
conta è accumulo. Tra i segnali diversi,
appartenenti a categorie diverse, in
molteplici incontri, in situazioni in
cui non sono forzati. Questo è uno
schema e gli schemi significano
qualcosa. Pensate a un medico. Nessun
bravo medico formula una diagnosi
basandosi su un singolo valore. Essi
considerano il quadro generale, i
molteplici valori nel tempo. È proprio
così che si capiscono le persone. Poniti
tre domande per ogni segnale. Ci
vogliono solo 5 secondi e ti faranno
risparmiare mesi. Innanzitutto, il
contesto lo spiega già, un bar
affollato, una lunga giornata di lavoro
e non conosce nessun altro alla festa.
Se la situazione spiega il
comportamento, ignorala. In secondo
luogo, lo fa con tutti. Se è così, è una
questione di carattere, non un tuo
segnale, lascia perdere. In terzo luogo,
le è costato qualcosa. Tempo,
deviazione, sforzo, rischio, apertura.
Questa è la domanda più cruciale di
tutte. Un segnale che non costa nulla è
di poco conto. Un segnale che costa
qualcosa è autentico. Tutto ciò che
supera tre filtri è oro. Tutto ciò che
non supera nemmeno un filtro non è mai
esistito. C'è un altro aspetto che
spesso viene dimenticato riguardo a
questo aumento. Tempo. Una singola
serata non è sufficiente per farsi
un'idea precisa. Le persone sono più
aperte, più calorose, più coraggiose in
certe serate per via del vino, della
musica o di una bella giornata che non
ha nulla a che fare con te. Ciò che
accade in una singola serata spesso
appartiene alla serata stessa, non a te.
Tutto ciò che rimane stabile nel corso
di tre incontri è tuo. Pertanto, qui la
pazienza non è esitazione, ma
precisione. La differenza tra le due è
semplice. La pazienza raccoglie.
L'esitazione nasconde, se dopo il terzo
incontro siete ancora in fase di
raccolta, non state più raccogliendo, vi
state nascondendo. E se dopo queste
domande non vi rimane molto da fare,
allora avete appena appreso una verità
scomoda, ma l'avete appresa. Ora vivilo
ora, non tra 4 mesi. È un dono, solo che
non sembra tale. Parte 7, il controtest.
Se hai torto ora, parleremo di un
argomento di cui quasi nessuno parla in
questo campo. È la domanda che
probabilmente vi frulla per la testa da
20 minuti. E se mi sbagliassi? Questa è
una domanda legittima, non è una
debolezza. E chiunque la ignori sta
cercando di venderti qualcosa, perché i
segnali non sono univoci. Le persone
inviano segnali contraddittori, non per
cattiveria, ma perché sono indecise. Lei
è aperta il martedì e distaccata il
venerdì, ed entrambe le manifestazioni
sono autentiche, perché nel frattempo ha
riflettuto: "Chiunque vi dica che basta
leggere i segnali e poi agire, vi ha
detto solo metà della verità e vi ha
nascosto l'altra metà ben più
pericolosa." Ecco la versione completa.
La tua percezione è una ipotesi, non ci
sono prove. Hai osservato degli schemi e
gli schemi sono probabilità. L'unico
modo per trasformare una probabilità in
certezza non è attraverso ulteriori
osservazioni, guida attraverso la
chiarezza. Ho provato entrambi gli
approcci ed è per questo che sto per
dirvi qualcosa che contraddice ciò che
di solito si sente dire su questo
argomento. La leadership non consiste
nel cercare di indovinare i propri
limiti. La leadership consiste nel
dichiarare le proprie intenzioni. L'uomo
che dà consigli lascia tutto il rischio
a lei. La costringe a frenare, a
sterzare bruscamente e a dire di no. lo
chiama coraggio. È l'esatto contrario.
L'uomo che parla apertamente si assume
il rischio, dice quello che pensa, si
rende vulnerabile ed è proprio questa la
cosa più attraente che una persona possa
fare. Ascoltate la frase che è stata al
centro di tutto: "Mi piaci". Mi
piacerebbe rivederti, ma non come
collega. 16 parole. Nessun trucco,
nessuna tecnica, non c'è bisogno di
interpretare segnali. 16 parole che
mettono fine a ogni dubbio che questo
intero video cerca di chiarire. E se lei
dicesse di no, allora lo saprai oggi
stesso, non tra 6 mesi. Un no è un
fallimento. Un no è il secondo miglior
risultato possibile, di gran lunga
migliore di anni di incertezza, di gran
lunga migliore di un'amicizia che tieni
in sospeso. Ecco la parte che devi
assolutamente ascoltare. Un uomo che
dichiara apertamente ciò che vuole e
riceve un no, non perde quasi nulla. Un
breve imbarazzante momento, qualche
giorno di orgoglio ferito e poi è
libero. Ciò che conserva è il rispetto
di una donna che non ha dovuto
sopportare per mesi qualcuno che voleva
qualcosa di diverso da ciò che aveva
ammesso. Ciò che perde non dicendo nulla
è tutto. Pertanto, non analizzate fino
allo sfinimento. Raccogliete i tre
indizi, verificateli con le tre domande
e poi parlate. Parte 8. Perché gli
uomini falliscono al traguardo? Siamo
giunti al punto in cui devo spiegarvi
perché tutto questo per la maggior parte
delle persone non funzionerà comunque,
non perché non riconoscano i segnali. I
segnali sono semplici, ormai li
conoscete. Ma esiste un muro tra la
consapevolezza e l'azione e quel muro si
chiama paura. La maggior parte degli
uomini desidera la certezza assoluta
prima di agire. Vogliono un segnale così
chiaro da non lasciare spazio a errori.
Raccolgono informazioni, aspettano,
confrontano, chiedono consiglio agli
amici, guardano persino un video come
questo. Questa certezza non arriva mai,
non esiste né nell'attrazione né in
nessun altro ambito della vita in cui
c'è qualcosa in gioco. Chi aspetta la
certezza aspetta per sempre. Non è un
proverbio, è una descrizione. Pertanto,
agli uomini accade qualcosa di molto
peggio del rifiuto. Non succede loro
nulla, non un no, ma nemmeno un sì, solo
un lento affievolirsi. Una donna che
all'inizio era aperta e che alla fine
smette di esserlo, perché non si possono
mandare messaggi all'infinito senza
ricevere una risposta. Non ha perso
interesse, ha smesso di aspettare e poi
lui se ne sta seduto lì a pensare che
lei non abbia mai provato niente. Lo
fece per mesi, ma lui non rispose mai.
Ho pagato questo prezzo e voglio che tu
lo guardi onestamente. Non sta nei
rifiuti che hai subito, ma nelle
conversazioni che non sono mai avvenute
perché stavi aspettando un segno che
avrebbe dovuto essere ancora più chiaro
dei 12 che lo hanno preceduto. Ora
passiamo alla parte che vi permetterà di
uscirne. Anche se hai torto, anche se
hai completamente torto, stai comunque
meglio di chi non fa nulla. Una donna
rispetterà sempre di più un uomo che
esprime apertamente e con rispetto i
propri desideri e accetta un no senza
fare scenate rispetto a uno che rimane
in silenzio per paura e tiene per sé i
propri desideri. Il primo lascia una
buona impressione anche quando dice di
no. Il secondo non lascia alcuna
impressione. Probabilmente hai speso
molte energie cercando di evitare gli
errori. Capisci una cosa? L'errore era
proprio l'evitamento. Parte 9.
L'alchimia del presente. C'è una cosa
che succede quando un uomo inizia a
vedere le cose in quel modo e ha poco a
che fare con le donne. Sarà presente.
Pensa a cosa hai effettivamente imparato
finora. Nessun trucco, nessuna frase da
memorizzare. Ha imparato dove guardare e
praticamente ogni risposta si riduceva
all'essere più presenti. Riconoscere
l'attenzione significa essere attenti.
Leggere la prossimità significa
percepire lo spazio in cui ci si trova.
Notare la memoria significa ascoltare se
stessi. Soportare la vulnerabilità
significa non scappare quando le cose si
fanno scomode. Questa non è una cassetta
degli attrezzi per le donne. Questo è
uno stile di vita. Ecco cosa succede e
perché per la maggior parte degli uomini
è come se si fosse acceso un
interruttore. Smetti di essere il
cercatore, diventi il veggente. Chi
cerca entra in una stanza e si chiede:
"Qualo mi noterà qui?". Il suo umore
dipende dalla risposta. È un supplicante
nella propria vita. Chi osserva entra
nella stessa stanza e semplicemente la
vede. Chi parla con chi, dove c'è
calore, dove c'è cortesia, chi è aperto
e chi no. Non sta cercando, sta
percependo. Poiché non è alla ricerca di
nulla, il suo atteggiamento è diverso,
non più duro, non più freddo, ma più
calmo. Ci percepisce a sufficienza da
evitare di fare supposizioni. Possiede
una serenità che non si può fingere.
Ecco il vero motivo per cui l'attenzione
è attraente. Non perché ti dica quando
colpire, ma perché chi sa davvero vedere
è diventato incredibilmente raro.
Viviamo in un mondo in cui due persone
siedono a un tavolo, entrambe con lo
sguardo fisso su uno schermo, dove si
sta conversando e si sta già formulando
la risposta, dove la presenza fisica è
diventata l'eccezione. Se sei una di
quelle persone al mondo che ascoltano e
ricordano, allora non hai bisogno della
tecnologia. Tu sei la tecnologia.
Infine, un'ultima cosa che vorrei
condividere con voi. Smetti di lottare
per l'attenzione perché la dai e perché
ciò che dai quasi sempre ti torna
indietro.
Conclusione: il tuo percorso verso la
vista. Oggi abbiamo parlato di più di
quattro segnali. Si trattava di
percezione, di cosa significhi essere
veramente presenti in uno spazio e di
come la differenza tra una vita in cui
non accade nulla e una in cui accade
tutto spesso consista in sole due cose:
guardare e parlare. Riassumiamo ciò che
hai a disposizione al momento.
Attenzione, dove si posa il suo sguardo
quando nessuno la guarda e se ritorna a
guardarla dopo essere stata interrotta?
dintorni, verso dove punta il suo corpo
e quanto dura l'addio memoria, ciò che
lei ha tenuto nascosto su di te, pur non
avendo alcun motivo di tenerlo nascosto.
Vulnerabilità. Nel momento in cui smette
di fare la brava ragazza, al di sopra di
tutto c'è la legge che tiene tutto
insieme, mai un singolo segno, sempre
l'accumulo, sempre il contesto, sempre
la domanda se ciò abbia comportato un
costo per loro. Un uomo che vede le cose
in questo modo, vive le sue giornate in
modo diverso, non tornerà mai più a casa
con la sensazione che qualcosa potesse
esserci e di cui non possa avere la
certezza, saprà a che punto si trova,
non dovrà più fare supposizioni, non
dovrà più sperare, non si chiederà più
se si sta solo immaginando tutto, perché
ha imparato a distinguere tra ciò che
desidera e ciò che sta realmente
accadendo nella stanza che inoltre
riceve qualcosa che ha solo una
connessione marginale con l'attrazione,
eppure cambia tutto. La pace a patto
ovviamente che faccia l'unica cosa che
rende utile la percezione in primo luogo
dire ciò che vede. Perché vedere senza
parlare non è progresso, è solo un modo
migliore per perdersi qualcosa. Prima di
andarvene vorrei che vi poneste una
domanda e vorrei che ci pensaste davvero
un attimo prima di continuare a
scorrere. Quante opportunità hai perso
l'anno scorso? Non perché sei stato
rifiutato, ma perché non hai mai detto
nulla. Pensate a quella situazione che
mi è appena venuta in mente mentre
ponevo quella domanda. Esiste? Esiste
per tutti. È esistita anche per me. Ecco
un compito per questa settimana, solo
uno. Ed è piccolo. Concentrati su un
singolo incontro con chiunque esso sia e
metti via completamente il telefono, non
sul tavolo. Via. Poi presta attenzione a
tre cose. Cosa dice? Cosa indica il suo
linguaggio del corpo e cosa ricorda di
te. Questo è tutto. Un incontro, tre
cose. Vi sorprenderà quante cose possano
accadere in una singola conversazione
una volta che una persona è
effettivamente presente. Mi chiamo
Daniel. Se questo video ti è stato
utile, metti un like, iscriviti al
canale e attiva le notifiche. Qui
affrontiamo argomenti che di solito
vengono solo accennati in modo onesto e
senza trucchi o favole su come si
suppone che le persone funzionino.
Scrivete nei commenti quale di questi
quattro segnali avete notato in qualcuno
senza capirne il significato all'epoca.
Li huletti davvero? E le risposte sono
spesso più interessanti del video.
Nell'angolo in alto a destra troverai il
video sulle tre frasi che gli uomini
usano per distruggere qualsiasi
attrazione senza rendersene conto. È il
passo successivo logico dopo questo. La
lingua è sempre stata lì. Ora puoi
leggerla, quindi parla.